our journey takes us to costa rica more
specifically tortuguero to witness the
yearly hatching of baby sea turtles and
meet the people protecting them
we arrive by way of la pavona a small
port town with one restaurant and a pay
toilet
our boat operator jairo guzman takes us
down the lucky river
it is a one hour journey to the island
itself
the view is beautiful
nearly all species of sea turtles are
endangered and this island is a
prominent nesting ground for both green
and leatherback sea turtles it was here
in 1959 the very first sea turtle
conservancy was opened by dr archie carr
to specifically study green sea turtles
as they were nearly extinct
this was their original base
this is their new base
along with us from the conservancy is
jaime head field director
david station manager
outreach coordinator and their 10
research assistants
they all work here to educate the public
and gather data on the current sea
turtle populations
[Music]
on day one we meet in the middle of the
night to count nesting turtles and the
eggs they lay now let's go to the beach
around dawn we spot a turtle she's
laying her eggs
she is one of 36 000 turtles nesting
this season on the beach each turtle
will lay around 110 eggs
in two months they will hatch
we get some sleep and that afternoon we
ask jaime about the hatchings take one
he says
the best time to catch it is right at
dawn around 5 30 in the morning
that means we have some down time on the
island
david invites us to his makeshift office
we discuss the vision of the conservancy
basically we are working here on the
legacy of dr archie carr he had this
idea of changing the mentality of the
people from harvesting the turtles for
their own consumption and for making
money out of the meat and the eggs into
an ecotourism-based
culture
it's a very complex thing to protect the
turtles
on day two the alarm goes off
the team gathers and we head to the
beach
we are going to need a bigger boat
[Music]
for a while we see nothing
and then
baby green sea turtles begin making
their way to the ocean
[Music]
only eighty percent will make it out of
the nest and of those one in one
thousand make it to adulthood
this means that out of nearly four
million hatchlings this season only
around 3 000 will become adults
and the odds are stacked against them
there's more down time
on our final day day three we go to the
beach to excavate a hatched nest
the research assistants do this job
it is
messy they're counting how many eggs
have hatched
in this nest nine did not make it
they'll add this information to their
decades of existing research
that afternoon jairo's father gusman
senior picks us up
as we leave tortuguero i can't help but
think of something silvia said back at
the base
[Music]
important
[Music]
sea turtles are not going to stop being
endangered this year
and they probably won't stop being
endangered next year either
but it's good to know that there are
people out there working hard to make
change happen
[Music]
you